ja die abonnenten und abonnenten von
flugangst haben sich gewünscht dass hier
ein kurzes video gebracht wird eine
ganze sendung über die frage wie wir
einen philosophischen sc verfassen das
mache ich sehr gerne
und zwar möchte ich jetzt ein paar
informationen dazu geben ich möchte aber
zugleich noch darauf hinweisen dass es
schon einmal eine themen sendung gab zur
frage wie man philosophische hause
wollten schreibt und dann mache ich oben
rechts den link zu dieser sitzung
hausarbeit und es ist ziemlich genau das
selbe und darauf geht es heute auch ein
bisschen um diese sache und ich werde
jetzt sagen was es sinn also es sind
kurze abhandlung vom wort her von der
wortbedeutung versuche
über ein eng umrissenes thema also es
ist nicht umfassend es ist keine
hausarbeit es ist keine abschlussarbeit
ist ein kurzer versuch ja was bedeutet
jetzt versucht es ist sollten wir hause
beiden eine klare leitfrage soll das ist
immer das wichtigste das sollte ein
problem vor augen und zwar bei es noch
kommentierte und noch eigenständiger als
browser ein das bedeutet und hat weniger
platz weniger raum in essays für die
entwicklung seiner gedanken das bedeutet
man muss ich mir konzentrieren man muss
mehr auf den punkt kommen man muss nicht
mehr alles in letzter hinsicht aus
buchstabieren kann sondern kann auch man
die dinge nur andere als oder auch
fragen stellen die themen
problematisieren aber nicht in letzter
konsequenz zu ende bringen das bedeutet
natürlich nicht dass es nicht
argumentativ seiner kasse ist sollten
noch viel argumentativer sein sondern
das sollte die argumentative struktur
noch viel stärker im zentrum stehen weil
eine umfassende diskussion der
sekundärliteratur wie im falle von hansa
beiden nicht nötig ist das erlaubt gar
nicht der geringen raum denen es bietet
oft genügt es sich nur auf wenige
der forschungsliteratur zu konzentrieren
es vielleicht nur auf eine diese dafür
aber sehr ernst zu nehmen und
argumentativ zu
problematisieren
das ist der fokus eines ss dem finger
lässt noch viel mehr auf das thema
bezogen noch vier freie auch im
themenbezug als eine hausarbeit
das hatte ich schon gesagt eine
argumentative charakter sollen sie
auffressen es hilft und sie sollten
eigene thesen formulieren und auch
verteidigen verteidigen kann man eigene
thesen auch dann wenn man sie mit einer
anderen position die eine gegenthese
darstellt konfrontiert
es sollte in drei teile gegliedert sein
das gilt eigentlich für alle
schriftlichen arbeiten in den
geisteswissenschaften speziell natürlich
auch in der philosophie die gliederung
ist ganz wichtig der einleitung sollten
sie das problem und die leitfrage
darlegen die sie dann im folgenden
hauptteil versuchen kommentiert zu
beackern muss nicht abschließend seien
aber zumindest sollten sie diese frage
ausdrücklich gehandelt im hauptteil
arbeiten sie dann diese beantwortung der
leitfrage die sind der einladung
aufgeworfen haben weiter aus und hier
ist ein argumentationspapier wichtig es
sollten zeigen dass ihre argumentationen
verschiedenen logisch aufeinander
aufbauenden schritten befolgt wird sie
sollte immer versuchen für ihre eigene
thesen überzeugende argumente anzuführen
und sie können auch versuchen ihre
argumente durch geschickt gewählte
beispiele zu belegen zu illustrieren
oder auch selbst sich gegen einwände
machen gegenargumente selbst entwickeln
die ihre eigene thesen betreffen und
dann entkräften in dem fall etwa man
könnte hier einbinden das aber bei
genauerem hinsehen erweist sich diese
einfach als nicht berechtigt so könnte
man zum beispiel sich einen eigenen
gegen ein land machen und dann bekommt
ein se auch eine diskursive struktur
eine quasi dialogische lebendige vor zum
schluss sollten sie eine pointierte
zusammenfassung der erzielten ergebnisse
geben und hier können sie auch noch ein
ausgegeben auf weiterführende probleme
und fragestellungen die sie jetzt in
dieser engen form in diesem engen rahmen
dieses essays nicht beantworten konnten
die sollten auf jeden fall nicht am ende
noch mal ein ganz neues fass aufmachen
sondern am ende sollten sie wirklich zum
schluss kommen und vielleicht noch mal
bezug herstellt zur in der einleitung
aufgebauten leitwerk dass diese eine
runde form bekommt
zum schluss möchte ich noch ein bisschen
eingehen auf die wahl des titels und des
untertitels essays sind das hatte ich
schon forciert und dass diese
projektierung bezieht sich auch auf die
form und auf den titel die titelgebung
also wie kann jetzt ein portierte
obertitel aussieht er kann zb bestehen
aus einem kurzen zitat wenn sie zum
beispiel ein philosophisches werk ein
essay behandelt worden suchen sie mal
nach einem guten
aussagekräftigen zitat das gibt es eine
kunst diese zitate ausfindig zu machen
und stellen die in anführungszeichen
followern vor dem untertitel also
stellen dieses zitat ihre messe voran
das ist eine möglichkeit sie können aber
natürlich auch eine interessante
zentrale wendung nehmen aus dem brk an
einem begriff und zwei wörter die in
ihrer kombination irgendwie
signifikant zentral vielleicht auch
problematisch sind sie können aber auch
eine provokative frage aufwerfen ja da
auch das ist etwas was ein se
charakterisiert sie sollten immer auch
an die leserin den leser denken wie
können sie dessen interesse wecken und
an sich ziehen das ist die frage wie
können sie eine mögliche leserin
auch irgendwie ja an die argumentation
inder dazu müssen sie auch durchaus
irgendwie provokative fragen nicht nur
im titel sondern auch im weiteren
verlauf des ss aufwerfen sie natürlich
immer auch argumentativ dann weiter
unterfüttert werden der untertitel der
sollte dann den provokativen obertitel
näher erläutern also wenn der obertitel
etwas unverständlich sein könnte weil er
ja portierte soder weißen zitat ist dann
sollte der untertitel da für klarheit
sorgen dass die leser die leserin am
ende schon weiß und mit erde sie ist
ungefähr zu tun haben und dass sie die
neugier des lesers wecken ja das war
eine kurze einführung in die frage
thematik wie man fische essence schreibt
ich wünsche allen zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer viel erfolg beim verfassen
ihrer ss